isabelle gimbert et la fille de
l'adjudant chef christian jambert son
père et le gendarme qui a permis de
résoudre la sphère des disparues de
l'yonne et de confondre le tueur en
série emile louis que square à auxerre
porte ce nom là tous au plus profond
d'elle-même
pour moi c'est une reconnaissance
extrême c'est une heure à sa mémoire
c'est pour sa mémoire et ce nom restera
et c'est effectivement par rapport au
travail qu'il a effectuée par rapport à
cette affaire qui pour lui est traitée
importante une affaire importante et
c'était assez sent une sorte
d'aboutissement l'enquêté le travail du
gendarme jambert ont été ignorés pendant
des années par la justice et la police
sans lui la sphère des disparues de
l'yonne n'aurait pourtant jamais éclaté
et le coupable
emile louis jamais inquiété pour pierre
mont noir ce square réhabilite en fait
la mémoire de christian jambert mieux
vaut tard que jamais et puis il faut
aussi que l'avenir soit un peu plus
ouvert et puis que ça serve un petit peu
de de morale un petit peu à tous ces
gens qui nous ont dit que nous allions
sali le département jambert c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a sali le département
c'est quelqu'un qui a défendu les plus
faibles il aura fallu plus de vingt ans
après la mort du gendarme christian
jambert pour que nommage officielle du
soir en bus mais pour la gendarmerie
l'essentiel est de saluer la mémoire et
le travail de l'un des siens
réhabilitation ça sera un mot trop fort
puisque maintenant on les faits sont
avérés et milou est décédé la plupart
des personnes témoins de l'époque ont
quitté le service actif
c'est peut-être le temps justement de la
reconnaissance historique en dehors de
toute polémique
et c'est peut-être là l'important la
plaque dédiée au gendarme christian
jambert se trouve juste à côté de la
stèle qui rendent hommage aux sept
disparues de l'yonne
désormais tous sont réunis en un seul et
même endroit où 16